cette semaine rando pays vous propose
une incursion en plein coeur de la forêt
de bébour sur le sentier de takamaka
pour découvrir le point de vue sur la
rivière des marsouins pour rejoindre le
départ de cette randonnée il faut
emprunter la route forestière de bébour
bélouve et se garer sur ce parking au
départ d'une piste fermé par une
barrière
indiquées sur les panneaux le point de
vue sur le barrage de takamaka constitue
le but de la randonnée et pour s'assurer
au maximum qu'il soit dégagé
mieux vaut emprunter la piste à l'aller
pour s'y rendre le plus rapidement
possible
au bout de la piste le spectacle est au
rendez vous la rivière des marsouins et
le barrage de takana k2 troisième
barrage hydroélectrique dont la
construction a été achevée en 1989
c'est un super point de vue qui est très
peu connue en fait qui est moins connu
que le troc vert mais à mon avis aussi
beau royal barrage en bas mais c'est
c'est aussi un intérêt c'est grâce à lui
qu'on a une partie de l'électricité à
dans l'île il ya des supers cascade
c'est un très très beau point de vue
c'est aussi une alternative au trou de
fer ou en plus du trou de fer il ya pas
mal d rico qui font ce parcours des
cascades dans la vallée de takamaka
donc c'est la rivière des marsouins en
fait les regards des marsouins de
saint-benoît et prend sa source en forêt
de bébour et passe comme ça de barrage
c'est vrai que la rivière des marsouins
coule toujours ya toujours de l'eau
c'est l'effet éponge faux répond la
forêt de bébour toutes les pluies qui
tombent à bébour bélouve en fait elle
reste un peu capté dans les mousses dans
l'est
les mettront un peu pour et dans toutes
les épiceries et puis ça libère l'eau
progressivement toute l'année
pour revenir par la piste peut être une
fin en soi mais ce serait se priver des
beautés comme la forêt de bébour
empruntez le sentier de takamaka en
direction de bélouve sept jours
seulement après le passage du cyclone
bingiza est en plus l'occasion de
découvrir comment la forêt a résisté aux
assauts du vent et de la pluie
et si le sol est jonché de feuilles
arrachées la présence de nombreuses
orchidées ou de bois en fleurs semblent
nous dire qu'elle n'a rien perdu de sa
superbe
peut-être alors les plus fortes
agression sur le milieu naturel vienne
tel d'ailleurs c'est lui là c'est le
palmiste rouge le palmiste en mx2 la
réunion donc uniquement si une pousse
qu'à la réunion et on le reconnaît bien
en forêt par ses grandes lignes
donc c'est le palmiste de forêts se
mange qui se mange et qui se mange hélas
encore en braconné et donc c'est
strictement interdit maintenant on
cultive du palmiste
donc on peut trouver du palmiste rouge
cultiver avec un poinçon de lodève pour
bénéficier ont pas miss cultivé et mais
encore pas mal de braconnage de palmiste
et à force on voit on fait vraiment
reculer avant il y en avait des milliers
y en avait autant que des fouilles
arbres sans nom dans ces forêts donc on
espère que progressivement les avons
respectés plus en plus et acheter leurs
pallice cultivé et pas du palmiste forêt
bras bolloc'h
saint charles
tu peux
ça
véritable réservoir d'eau la forêt de
bébour n'a pourtant pas l'habitude de
voir ces ravine coulait à flot avec les
fortes pluies du cyclone elles se sont
gonflés ils nous offrent un décor des
plus agréables
jusque là le sentier était plutôt propre
même si quelques rares arbres ont chuté
mais au niveau d'une station de vigne
marronne les espèces exotiques par
excellence c'est un véritable
enchevêtrement de ronces qui nous
barrent le chemin les forêts indigènes
là la vraie forêt de la réunion les
espèces locales pays et indigènes elle
supporte très bien les cyclones et sont
bien adaptés éventuellement et se couche
mais la plupart des arts ou une fois
couché il meurt pas et par contre les
espèces qui viennent de l'extérieur
elles et sont pas du tout adaptés à ce
climat et la basse et champ de bataille
le raisin marron ne s'est pas à une
plante pays s'étaient introduits cette
exotique elle lui tient pas du tout aux
cyclones comme l'eucalyptus qui casse
vraiment vos cool
le doudou lanfains il ya beaucoup
d'espèces comme ça qu'ils exotiques qui
tiennent pas du tout et dans les forêts
c'est plutôt qui souffre des cyclones
que les espèces indigènes peu
la pluie s'est invitée au sol sur les
arbres l'eau oui celle de toute part
progressé dans une forêt tropicale sous
la pluie c'est une ambiance différente
même si les images en pâtissent fa
au bout de 5 km c'est le retour sur le
bitume de la route forestière et pour
retrouver la voiture et le parking il
faut redescendre sur une centaine de
mètres
ce sentier il permet d'avoir un très
très beau point de vue sur la rivière
des marsouins sur les cascades près de
takamaka du barrage de sacs à 2 et
permet en retour ou enfin là les deux
selon sens non l'a fait au retour de
découvrir la forêt de bébour la réserve
biologique pour être débarqué il ya une
forêt magnifique et ses franges ans et
palmistes ou énormément de bois de
belles belles forêts moi j'aime beaucoup
les forêts de l'est ce même si on est
très très souvent sous la pluie ça fait
partie de l'ambiance de ces forêts en
fait assez d'efforts et humide qui
n'aime pas quand il pleut pas on voit
les plantes épiphytes qui pend qui
pendouille qui sont toutes tout reste
honnête quand il fait beau trop
longtemps en anglais andy rain forest
c'est c'est vraiment de la forêt humide
doit pour être cuite et les ambiances de
brouillard même de fortes pluies comme
on allait aujourd'hui moyenne gamme ça
fait partie de l'ambiance